alright i'm justin and i'm here with
peter we're at CES 2014 we just got done
checking out the oculus rift but this is
a slightly different one than once we've
seen previously what was what was
different about this one so the brand
new prototype is code named Crystal Cove
and one of the biggest things I've got
going now is positional tracking in the
past the oculus would let you turn your
head a little bit but now you can move
it in XY space and you can actually see
that reflected in the game itself so
it's pretty important imagine a game
like where you're trying to take cover
behind something and you actually move
before that wasn't something you could
do and the demo is in a sort of a small
environment but now with that tech
that's something the oculus rift will
support and that had these kind of bumps
all over it they were there was a
specific name for that I'm just calling
a box because I have no idea well it's
like motion capture right it's those
little tracking dots and they use a
camera and they keep they keep track of
where those are relative to the camera
lens so as you move it says okay well
there go those dots there goes the
perspective in the game one of the other
things they added is a new what their
labeling as improved persistence pixels
now flick on and off and it's sort of a
it's a different way of buffering a
frame so in the past when you would say
strafe left and right but rather turn
your head left it right or looking at
text it will look kind of blurry but
things are a lot more sharper now
especially when you're pivoting in space
and for me this is the first time that
I've tried it out i have have not had
the earlier versions of this which
didn't work quite the same way and it
really is just this amazingly immersive
experience like you you look down and
you expect to see your hands reaching up
around you and talking with the guys
they were like well yeah we're not
ruling out the possibility of that but
it's still very early days yeah they're
doing a lot of internal testing but
right now one of the important things is
really nailing VR and with VR every
little every little bit of tech counts
and they equated it to building a house
of cards and everything that they're
adding and putting the improve
persistence and the positional tracking
is just adding another card to that
house and getting it bigger and bigger
until you have the full realization of
the product so while it'd be great to
have shoulder tracking and all these
individual like digits moving in the
game it's still a ways off they're still
working really hard to get this finished
and the Crystal Cove prototype that they
showed very fragile is like 3d print
display these little things added on to
it so we're still far aways away they're
not
[ __ ] consumer model yet but all these
things will be available when that
shifts the thing that they were using to
show off this this version of it where
you're able to lean in it is kind of a
tower defense game it's not of course a
real working game but just us to be able
to show off being able to zoom in and
see your your creatures close-up it or
be able to pull back and see the whole
field of view yeah you were essentially
a player looking over a game that was
happening in the space in front of you
and you could like lean in and look down
and the guys and it was interesting
experience but what I really loved it
which I got to play a games com which is
even better now with the positional
tracking is Eve Valkyrie it's the guys
from who designed you know Eve the the
massive like you know space game gcp CCP
guys correct and and these guys designed
this game for the rips from the
beginning and it definitely shows it's
one of the best experiences on the rift
I've ever had the pleasure of enjoying
and I just I can't wait to play more and
every time oculus adds one more thing to
the rips it just gets better and better
and I sound like I'm just gushing but I
am because it's it's really great that
sense of speed is you're going down the
tunnel it's like you're actually flying
it's this weird out-of-body experience
but it's so cool I really can't wait to
see the next iteration or even the the
actual final version of this once I
start coming out of it it's it is
definitely very cool very future tech
we're gonna see more at GDC so for now
thanks Justin thanks Peter stay tuned in
gamespot play more CES coverage to come
we got two more days of the show up to
cover follow us on Twitter Facebook and
YouTube more to come stay tuned